Isaac Asimov was my favorite science
fiction writer and his favorite science
fiction story talked about an era far in
the future when our bodies would be in
pause and we would mentally control
beings beings of pure energy they would
go flying around the universe and of
course it was science fiction but here's
the idea mind without body pure
consciousness roaming across the
universe faster than any rocket ship it
turns out that that's actually a
physical possibility first of all the
Obama administration and the European
Union are pushing the brain project to
delineate all the pathways of the human
brain this means that one day we might
have a cd-rom called brain 2.0 that is
every single neuron encoded on a memory
disk your personality your memories who
you are the essence of your soul will be
incorporated in this disk as pure
information even if you die your
consciousness in some sense may live on
now you as a organic being will have
died that means that your neurons will
turn to dust but the configuration of
neurons that made your thinking process
possible can be put on a disk in which
case in some sense you become immortal
not only immortal but this could be the
most efficient way to explore the galaxy
just like Isaac Asimov predicted in his
short story let's say I take you're not
your genome but your connectome put it
on a laser beam in fact in the book I
actually calculate how big a laser beam
will be required to put your
consciousness as pure photons shine it
into the heavens you're now shooting
consciousness into outer space at the
speed of light forget booster rockets
forget asteroid collisions for
get radiation dangers and weightlessness
and lack of oxygen forget all that you
are writing on a laser beam at the speed
of light and then at the end is a relay
station a relay station which takes the
laser beam and then puts it into a
surrogate that is all the neural
networks encoded in the laser beam can
be manifested as a robot on the other
side of the galaxy so in other words
it's like staying at a hotel if you're a
businessman you go from hotel to hotel
and relax same way you'd be on a laser
beam going from relay station to relay
station and when you go to the real
estate you take the robot body of a
superhuman you become Superman
on the other end of the rainbow so is
this a physical possibility yes when
might we have it but let's be honest it
would take perhaps a hundred years or so
before we have a complete understanding
of the connectome that is all the neural
pathways of the brain perhaps another
century beyond that before we have relay
stations on which we could then shoot
our consciousness into outer space
is it mathematically and physically
possible and the answer is yes
you